Speaker 1: You guys are probably familiar
with Jessica TARLOV on Fox News.
She's the one liberal host on the five, and
she just does a really good job of effectively
knocking down a lot of these right wing talking
points in real time as they're being spewed
on the fly by the other hosts.
And I have an example of that for you here.
In relation to Hunter Biden and producer Pat
on yesterday's show talked about how Hunter
Biden is expected to plead guilty to two misdemeanor.
Charges in relation to not paying his taxes.
He has since, but he did it for a time there
for two years and he's pleading guilty to
those charges, misdemeanors and then will
have a felony charge in relation to lying
on a form about getting a firearm even though
he was addicted to a controlled substance.
He said that he wasn't and that allowed him
to get that firearm.
And so that felony charge is going to be dismissed
if he follows through with certain guidelines.
And of course, you can expect and I think
pretty sharp had predicted this yesterday,
the right wing has been saying this is a big
example of a two tiered justice system.
It's a sweetheart deal.
And he's being treated with kid gloves because
he's Hunter Biden.
And see, this is this is what we've been saying.
But in reality, it's not an example of that.
It's not an example of Hunter Biden getting
preferential treatment, as Jessica TARLOV
will point out very nicely.
I will note these charges and the investigation
didn't uncover or it doesn't have to do with
all these accusations we've heard from the
right wing.
So that's part of the reason why they're really
unhappy and want this to be an example of
the two tier justice system.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess I could ask.
It's certainly been trickling out since Saturday,
which was the first official campaign event,
and then Hunter was going to be a major talking
point on the campaign, and that is slowly
going away, but for good reason.
So to try to tackle all the points that everybody
made, which were aplenty.
So what Hunter is not guilty of is being a
Republican, but there's a Republican very
closely allied with Trump named Roger Stone,
who did worse than Hunter Biden.
So he tax evaded $2 million, not 1.2 million,
$2 million.
And guess what happened?
He was allowed to pay it back and he wasn't
even criminally charged.
Hunter Biden, criminally charge, could face
probation.
Roger Stone, top Guide Is Donald Trump skates
free on that it seems.
Speaker 3: Didn't they raised his hand?
Yeah.
Speaker 2: I was just going to say, isn't
he the guy I was seeing?
Cursing?
No.
You think guns blazing about everyone just
because someone is carrying a gun?
No one shot up any houses.
No one was forced out of their house.
I know they tipped off CNN, though, to be
the huge crime of having CNN there.
Okay.
Speaker 3: But I love the fact that you like
guns now.
Speaker 2: I really don't.
And actually, I think that there should be
stricter gun control in this country.
But if you look at the DOJ records about how
often what Hunter Biden did is actually charged,
it's basically No. 219 a.
Speaker 3: Lil Wayne.
Speaker 2: Do you notice I didn't interrupt
a single person on the panel, so just give
me a sense.
I am so sorry.
In 2019, there were 298 98 cases brought of
people falsifying their gun application records
out of 27 million background checks that were
completed.
That's the year that Hunter Biden got that
weapon.
That means that this is something that doesn't
get charged.
If you want to say to the DOJ, you should
be charging on this, go ahead and do that.
But there's no reason that one.
Speaker 1: HUNTER Absolutely.
So, number one, just surface level thing.
If you're a viewer of Fox News and you see
that.
Don't you think that.
I mean, just the the way the style in which
they present information, the difference between
Jessica TARLOV and the other hosts and how
they're jumping in like children.
Well, what about this?
Oh, you like guns now.
And not actually making serious points while
she's calmly presenting actual facts, just
the esthetic seems clear, separate from the
substance of the points that are also clearly
better to be a much more, um, of depth presentation
of the facts.
But on the substance of what she's talking
about, it's important that we go one by one
so that later on, as they list off all the
reasons, I think there's a duty of justice
to it and we can reference all the different
debunking that have been done by us as well.
Media, Batman, whoever it might be.
Because as this narrative gets built, it becomes
all these examples that on their own, as we'll
talk about here, as we are currently, aren't
actually examples of the future justice system,
but people don't hear that and so they get
a bunch of examples.
See, Hunter Biden got this deal is a sweetheart
deal.
Just believe us.
But we're not providing evidence of that.
Or the FBI.
I did this thing and that thing that we're
not really providing evidence for.
And so the people have a collection of examples
in their heads and they think, Oh my gosh,
surely even if I hear one thing get knocked
down here and there, surely there is this
two two justice system that hurts Republicans
and benefits Democrats because of all these
examples I've been hearing.
When in reality, if we go one by one.
They don't hold water.
They're not examples of Biden weaponizing
the government against conservatives or to
benefit his son or to benefit Democrats.
It's just not something that's happening.
And it's really unfortunate so many people
are buying into that.
I went to the Miami arrest of Trump, as many
of you guys saw and talked to a lot of Trump
supporters as they were really unhappy.
And I would ask them, okay, so you read the
indictment and you think that the evidence
is is not real, or do you think that the law
doesn't apply here?
Or why do you think this is so horrible that
Trump is being held accountable?
And I think every person said, well, I haven't
read the indictment or I haven't read the
whole indictment, most of them just that I
haven't even seen the indictment.
So then how could you possibly know that this
is an example of Trump being politically persecuted?
And then it would be, well, what about Hillary?
Well, what about Hunter Biden?
And as we're trying to do with this example
and you can do with those individual ones,
if you dive into the specifics, you understand
why.
Oh, that's not an example of unfair treatment.
That's an example of that being a different
case with different facts that was investigated
and yielded different results, not because
of a bias, but because of different facts,
sometimes lead investigators to different
conclusions.
And that's perfectly fair.
But now this view that anything done to a
Republican, a conservative that is prominent
and is an example in reality of them being
held accountable for their violations of the
law.
In the case of Trump, of course, very prominently
actually just fits into the world view that's
already been created for so many people that
conservatives are being persecuted.
One more example of this being fact checked
real quick.
Speaker 3: Obviously, you're already hearing
a lot of shouting.
Oh, sweetheart.
Deal.
Oh, this.
Oh, that.
None of us really knows the details of the
possible charges here and exactly what was
agreed to as part of this plea.
Jennifer, but how do how does one assess whether
this is the type of deal that a normal person,
not a president child would get in this circumstance?
Speaker 6: So you would look to other similar
cases, right.
So on the gun form charge.
It's very, very standard for someone in this
situation who lies on the form because they're
an addict.
The gun is long gone, apparently only had
it for a couple of weeks.
It's very standard in these circumstances
for this diversion to occur and to wipe out
the charges, assuming he's successfully completed
it.
So that's totally standard.
And the tax fraud is is similar as well.
I mean, he paid those taxes back a long time
ago.
That's something that DOJ takes very, very
seriously when negotiating these deals.
And I'll also say that Hunter Biden was an
addict at the time.
And so there was discussion of this back when
this investigation got going.
When you're talking about a drug addict, you
have to think about whether you can prove
the mens rea.
It this goes to trial.
Is he going to be able to undercut their case
about whether he knowingly and willfully didn't
pay his taxes?
So given all of that and given similar cases
with tax fraud, this is not a sweetheart deal.
It's a deal.
I think it's a good deal for Hunter Biden
in that he will stay out of prison and end
up with only two misdemeanors on his right.
Speaker 1: So facts matter.
And if you look at the facts of this case,
it doesn't fall within the narrative that
they're trying to build day after day.
Thank you all so much for watching today's
show.
Again, you can find me at Luke Beasley on
YouTube.
And if
you're
a member, I'll see you.
Unidentified: On
the show.